Trump has been touting a 51% approval rating
from some very specific right-leaning pollsters,
but the reality is that Donald Trump's approval
rating has dropped to its lowest in 2019,
which is 36% this is looking at one poll that
has been done over time.
It's the Associated Press poll.
It's been tracking Trump's approval for his
entire presidency.
And right now Trump's approval is 36% his
disapproval is 62% so let's contextualize
this.
Let's explain why it matters and then let's
talk about how it relates to 2020.
First of all, the context, Trump's approval
has been in the range of 32 to 42 in the Associated
Press poll since day one.
So it didn't go lower than 32% approval.
It's never been higher than 42% approval.
That's a small range of only 10 points.
That one, one thing that relates to is the
hyper partisanship and polarization in the
United States politically.
We've talked about that before.
Right now Trump is at 36 that's pretty close
to the middle of that 32 to 42 range, a little
bit on the lower end, and that ties the lowest
approval of 2019 so is this some kind of breaking
news that changes everything? Trump approval
at 36 well, not in the sense that Trump is
in the middle of the approval range that he's
had all presidency.
Secondly, some partisan context, if you look
at Democrats, 95% disapprove of Trump, republicans
approve 79% and independence approve 65% that's
an important number.
The 79% that Republicans approve.
This is important because Trump's been touting
and Republicans have been leaning on, Trump
has 95% approval among Republicans.
I don't know what poll that is.
This is a good poll that we're looking at
and it says, hold on a second.
79% of Republicans approve of Trump.
This matters in the context of a primary challenger,
which now Donald Trump has in former congressman
Joe Walsh.
And I'll be talking about that later in the
show.
95% approval from your party and 79% approval
from your party are two very different things.
And in a primary, the goal of which would
be not to defeat Donald Trump in the primary,
it's not going to happen, but to do some damage
to Trump, uh, that is going to be significantly
influenced by the difference between Republicans
approving of Trump.
79% versus 95% so that's important.
Also important.
There are three areas where Republicans actually
disapprove of Trump's handling more than they
disapprove of him overall.
So again, remember, 79% of Republicans approve
of Trump.
However, only 77% think he's handling healthcare
correctly.
Only 75% say he's handling foreign policy
correctly and only 70% believe he's handling
gun policy correctly.
This is important and it's interesting, but
Republicans are not going to vote for a Democrat
because they disagree with Trump on these
issues.
This is important to understand for Democrats,
gun policy isn't a voting issue by and large
for Republicans, gun policy can be a voting
issue if you are on the wrong side of more
guns and more places, but the reality is if
you're a republican and you don't love Trump's
take on guns, you're not going to go and vote
for a Democrat over that.
That's the reality.
Health Care, a lot of these Republicans, 25%
of them, they might recognize Trump is completely
bungling healthcare, but they're not going
to go and vote for a so called socialist healthcare
plan from a Democrat.
They're still going to vote Trump.
They just don't like what he's doing on healthcare.
Similarly foreign policy foreign policy is
just not a voting issue in the way that domestic
economic issues are.
So that gets us to what do we do with this
data, whether it's 36% approval or 32% approval
or even in the 20s Donald Trump can still
win reelection.
I've, I've run the numbers before with you
half the country doesn't vote.
You could have a 26% approval and turn out
1% more voters in some key states than the
other party and win because half the country
doesn't vote.
So following Donald Trump's approval is relevant
and it helps us to understand how people,
especially Republicans are reacting to Trump.
It does not tell us anything about what's
going to happen in 2020 all you need to know
is that Donald Trump could have a 36% approval
rating and easily win.
And by the way, the fact that he has a 36%
approval rating tells us that there are tens
of millions of people who are so disconnected
from reality or ideologically blinded that
they don't care what happens in the real world.
They are voting for Trump in 2020 period.
Okay? Trump has tens of millions of votes
in 2020 already.
It's August of 2019.
The elections in November of 2020 Trump has
tens of millions of votes.
Once you know that, you realize this becomes
get out the vote because we're not going to
be able to convince these people in any large
numbers.
I know I'm a broken record at this point.
I've been talking about this for so long.
This is going to be about get out the vote
that needs to be our priority in our context
heading into 2020.
Uh, tell me if you think there is some other
way in which Trump's approval is relevant
beyond reminding us he's got tens of millions
of votes in the bank already and we've got
to get the vote out.
Follow us on Instagram at instagram.com/david
Pakman show and Oh, uh, I have a new story
on my Instagram page.
David.
Dot.
Pacman got back from vacation.
Big Development
because my tomato plants huge developments.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at instagram.com/data.cox